todos los miembros del consejo de
seguridad de la onu aprobaron una
resolución presentada por eeuu y méxico
el proyecto de resolución ha sido
aprobado por unanimidad el texto pide a
los estados miembros de la onu prohibir
la venta de armas pequeñas a pandillas
haitianas también incluye disposiciones
y sanciones dirigidas a los líderes de
estas bandas de mende el mandato refleja
los desafíos clave que enfrenta haití
incluía la necesidad de abordar el
tráfico ilegal de armas y los flujos
financieros ilícitos la resolución
detiene un embargo total solicitado por
china sólo esta semana casi 90 personas
murieron en medio de la guerra entre
bandas en puerto príncipe desde el
asesinato del presidente yo en el movice
el año pasado la violencia ha ido en
aumento y las pandillas se están
aprovechando de la inestabilidad
política que vive el país los precios en
el mercado negro se han disparado
arribando aún más la crisis en la
capital los manifestantes quemaron
neumáticos y bloquearon carreteras por
el alza de los precios del combustible
si se empeñan en subir los precios del
petróleo prendemos fuego al país
el aumento de la inseguridad los
repetidos secuestros y la escases de
combustibles son las principales
dificultades que enfrentamos en el país
los secuestros también aumentan en junio
se presentaron 155 casos frente a 118 de
reportados en mayo la mitad de los
haitianos vive por debajo del umbral de
la pobreza y las agencias de ayuda dicen
que acceder a ciertas zonas es peligroso